bonjour luc chatel bonjour voit de plus
en plus défendre nicolas sarkozy encore
quelques minutes sur le dossier air
cocaïne vous êtes son conseiller
politique
quel rôle allez vous jouer dans les mois
à venir alors que la bataille pour la
primaire va s'intensifier moi je
souhaite tout simplement que notre
famille gagné les élections de 2017 est
calé à redresser ce pays
voilà donc c'est ça qui m'intéresse le
reste ne m'intéresse pas et je souhaite
que nous abordions cette période qui va
pas être simple parce qu'après les
régionales va voir les primaires dans la
campagne on sait ce que c'est justement
sur lesquels nous l'abordions avec
sérénité avec force celui moi j'ai
essayé des deux dernières années d'être
utile à ma famille politique
j'en étais le secrétaire général dans
des moments très difficiles où notre
moment a failli disparaître ou il y
avait des tensions comme n'y avait
jamais eu depuis 25 ou 30 ans voilà donc
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est que à la
fin on fasse jouer le débat sur les
primaires je pense que c'est nécessaire
que chacun puisse s'exprimer
il ya des sensibilités différentes il ya
des talents différents mais il ya
beaucoup de talent alors on sent il ya
beaucoup d'idées
donc il faut bien oui mais vaut mieux le
trot que le le paas exemple à la
bataille s'intensifie
j'observe un truc c'est qu'il ya
quelques mois on expliquer qu'on n'avait
pas d'idées on n'est pas de projet et on
faisait que de la politique politicienne
aujourd'hui on nous explique qu'il ya
trop de mesures dans le projet sur la
sécurité
est-ce qu'il ya encore un peu de
politique politicienne demain samedi il
ya un conseil national des républicains
à la salle de la mutualité un grand
discours nicolas sarkozy est attendu
il y aura des absents très remarqué je
parle évidemment de françois fillon
alain juppé bruno le maire qui ne seront
pas là
est ce qu'on y voit un boycott vis-à-vis
nicolas sarkozy sort sûrement je ne
pense pas ils sont présents
régulièrement en bureau politique et
paris n'était pas là mardi lors de la
moitié travaillent sur la sécurité mais
tu t'amènes deux événements majeurs du
parti auquel des ténors ne participe pas
demandé leur dire moi je suis déçu parce
que vous êtes à l'intérieur comme
envoûté les choses de l'intérieur non
moi je trouve ça dommage ça vous le dis
franchement j'en serai non mais je
trouve ça dommage pourquoi castro toi
c'est quoi l'objet du conseil national
de samedi
c'est d'investir deux candidats aux
élections régionales
donc on donne aux excès originale ils
sont pas en train de choisir le candidat
à la primaire
puis c'est pas les militants des
républicains qui vont choisir quand
imprimés recéler français sympathisants
de droite et du centre donc c'est un
rendez vous important pour nos candidats
ils vont aller aux élections
ils attendent quoi nos candidats nos
électeurs ils attendent quoi c'est qu'on
montre qu'on est rassemblée qu'on est
unis
car ensuite bien sûr il ya des je suis
pas naïve luc chatel ya des sensibilités
différentes
on n'est pas d'accord sur tout sarkozy a
proposé des choses mardi que je paie ou
fillon avec lesquels ils sont pas
forcément d'accord ok c'est la politique
mais là on est derrière nos candidats
aux régionales c'est un rendez vous
important
ben moi je trouve ça trop tôt s'ils
peuvent encore changer d'avis je trouve
ça bien qu'il vienne vous dites dommage
est-ce que c'est pas une faute politique
de laisser nicolas sarkozy tout seul sur
l'autoroute comme ça c'est votre
interprétation mais nicolas sarkozy il
avance voilà il a été élu par les
militants de l'ump à l'époque pour
redresser le parti il à apaiser la
situation il rassemble il engrange des
succès électoraux et il prépare le
projet jan fois il vous avez fait sens
que je revienne phrase que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure qui m'a interpellé
si on avait tout bien fait lors du
précédent quinquennat on aurait été
réélu est ce que justement le fait que
nicolas sarkozy était battu en 2012
n'est pas un handicap majeur en vue
d'une possible réélection en 2017 ça
c'est une question que vous ne poserez
le moment c'est vous qui l'avez abordé
tout à l'heure oui non madame n'est pas
abordée de métier j'ai abordé le passé
oui j'ai eu le débat précédent et
écoutez je serais si aujourd'hui vous
commencez à dire aux français mais on a
tout ce qu'on a fait était formidable
moi je ne fais pas plus la politique
comme ça c'est pas possible ça exaspère
les français voilà donc oui on n'a pas
fait les choses bien
même moi je vais vous dire j'ai pas fait
que des choses rien quand j'étais
ministre aoun et 3 croyable incroyable
politique alors très rapidement pour
terminer cette séquence je vous fait
réagir pardon à trois séquences de
communication politique de cette semaine
la première c'était la semaine dernière
françois hollande chez l'habitant
bfmtv a révélé que la rencontre chez
lucette qui est désormais très connu
avait été montée de toute pièce est ce
qu'il s'agit
voilà d'un est ce qu est ce que françois
hollande s'est piégé lui-même en sa
propre boulimie de communication j'ai
trouvé ça pathétique
pourquoi que françois hollande voit des
entre guillemets vrais français très
bien voilà mais à ce moment là qu ils
les reçoivent à l'elysée en toute
discrétion ce qui nous expliquent qu'ils
apprennent des sécurités de machin c'est
pas quand même plaisant attendait qui
les invite à l'elysée bon ensuite j'ai
entendu ce justifié on nous explique
arnaud mais ce n'était pas une opération
de communication
ah oui donc c'est passé en ligne sur
tous les réseaux sociaux sur les médias
il y avait cette pauvre lucette
avec 17 ministres et députés autour
d'elle dans sa salle à manger étriqué
infligeant deux hommes séquence une
chanson de frédéric cuvillier qui est
tête de liste dans le dans le pas de
calais contre marine le pen on écoute un
petit extrait
condé
je suis content
est ce que c'est de la bonne
communication
à titre personnel je ne pense pas bon là
je veux dire il nous est arrivé aux
républicains de faire ce genre de choses
je pars je pense que je pense que à
chaque fois que les responsables
politiques se mettent en scène il se
trompe
nous ne sommes pas des stars des actes
c'est pas vrai les français qu'est ce
qu'ils attendent c'est qu'on réponde à
leurs problèmes
voilà je trouve pas que s'agrandisse je
parle même pas de frédéric cuvillier le
candidat les candidats la politique de
manière générale dernière séquence
rapidement le clip diffusé par le
ministère de l'éducation cette semaine
contre le harcèlement scolaire c'est un
sujet très sérieux on en regarde un
extrait des lames de la classe baptiste
baptiste tu es avec nous
alors les syndicats d'enseignants sont
montés monté au créneau pour ce plan
d'une image caricaturale des enseignants
vous avez été ancien médication vous
êtes exprimé d'ailleurs sur cette
question du harcèlement scolaire
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
polémique est ce qu elle a justifié je
me suis pas exprimé c'est moi qui ai
lancé qui était le premier ministre a
lancé la politique de lutte contre le
harcèlement à l'école donc j'adhère
complètement à cette campagne qui est
exactement dans l'esprit des clips que
j'avais moi même lancée en 2011 voilà le
les élucubrations des enseignants j'y
suis habitué il faut des mains mais bien
sûr si voulez on a besoin de lutter
contre l'omerta et le harcèlement à
l'école c'est 10 % des élèves et
pourquoi j'ai pour vous pourquoi j'ai
agi parce que j'ai été bouleversé par
des témoignages de parents qui sont venu
m'expliquer me parler ce qui arrivait à
leurs enfants
cela peut pas vous laisser indifférent
voilà donc les corporatismes dans ces
cas là c'est franchement déplacé place
merci merci